thanks to dashlane for sponsoring this
video find out more later in the video
hey 42 here science fiction films and
books have done a pretty remarkable job
of predicting the future
jules verne imagines the moon landing
just over a hundred years before it
actually took place
in from the earth to the moon
george orwell glimpsed aspects of
governmental surveillance in his seminal
novel 1984.
and edward bellamy dreamt up cards that
could be used to make payments
all the way back in 1888.
it's him we have to thank for the term
credit card by the way
but one of the most famous sci-fi tropes
of them all
teleportation
is still yet to come to pass
or is it
believe it or not teleportation is
actually already possible
and i don't just mean theoretically
possible either those sneaky scientist
types have been at it for years
the bad news is this particular kind of
teleportation is a little bit different
to the handy just teleporting to the
shops to get some milk kinds most often
depicted in sci-fi films
but before i get on to that i need to
clear something up
since we're talking about sci-fi and
teleportation the obvious place to start
is with star trek and when i mention the
words star trek and teleportation in the
same sentence that little part of your
brain that makes subconscious
connections has probably already said
beam me up scotty inside your head
as you probably know this legendary
catchphrase was uttered by captain kirk
to his chief engineer scotty whenever he
wanted to return to his ship via its
handy transporter
an expensive optional upgrade on all top
of the line starships
except that's never actually happened
not the teleporting bit
i mean the catchphrase
never once in the history of the
original star trek series and films was
the phrase beam me up scotty ever
uttered
that's some mandela effect fuel right
there and you can add fuel to your
personal security with dashlane who've
kindly sponsored today's video dashlane
creates strong and unique passwords for
all your online accounts and autofills
them so you never have to click forgot
password ever again and you don't have
to sweat about the extremely rare chance
that dashlane could be breached because
dashlane safely stores and decrypts your
data on your local device only using
your master password
this means that dashlane never has
access to your personal data and any
hacker would only see random noise
dashlane also also fills your credit
card information whilst online shopping
so you can make purchases without having
to fetch your wallet dashlane has a
built-in vpn to encrypt your data and
keep your online activity anonymous best
of all it works on any device so whether
you're protecting your top secret
blueprints to your teleportation machine
or just videos of your cat there's
honestly no better way to make your
online world impenetrable than by using
dashlay from my experience dashlane is
the best all-bases covered security and
time-saving tool out there you can try
dashlane for free on your first device
by heading to www.dashlane.com
forward slash 42
then if you decide you want to upgrade
to premium use my code 42 for 10 percent
off
anyway as i mentioned teleportation is
actually already here
scientists proved it was possible
theoretically way back in 1993
and the first actual teleportation was
carried out experimentally in 1997
but as you've probably already gathered
considering your daily commute is almost
certainly not via teleporter
unless your office address happens to
include the words area 51
what we're talking about here is not
full-on human teleportation
in fact it isn't even teleportation of
inanimate objects
what scientists currently refer to as
teleportation is for the most part
quantum teleportation
and quantum teleportation is
i'm afraid to say
kind of cheating
starters we're only able to use it to
teleport quantum information not
physical matter
that has some pretty exciting
implications for things like quantum
computing and specifically a quantum
internet but it isn't all that much use
for human teleportation at least not yet
quantum teleportation relies on what
einstein famously once called spooky
action at a distance
which now has the slightly more grown-up
name of quantum entanglement if you're
interested in exactly what that is then
i can highly recommend dedicating a
significant portion of your life to
getting a degree in physics but for a
somewhat watered-down youtube version
quantum entanglement occurs when two
particles become linked entangled
so that their quantum states are
interdependent in essence the entangled
particles act as a single quantum object
that means that if we do something to
one of the particles like measure its
momentum or spin
that action is reflected in the quantum
state of the entangled particle two
the spooky part about all of this as
einstein put it is that two entangled
particles will continue to act as a
single quantum object in this way no
matter how far apart they are
that means a physical operation carried
out on a particle here on earth
would be reflected instantaneously on
its entangled partner particle
even if it was literally on the other
side of the universe
scientists use this incredibly weird
property along with some ingenious
jiggery pokery that allows them to
circumvent heisenberg's uncertainty
principle
to transfer or teleport information
across large distances
the current record stands at 1
400 kilometers
but if we're being completely honest the
use of the word teleport here
is pretty misleading
in fact i've got half a mind to report
science to the advertising standards
authority on grounds of false
advertising
this isn't really teleportation not in
the sense you or i or star trek meant it
quantum teleportation is about the
transfer of information data
no physical matter is moved at all
but
thinking about it
information is powerful stuff
and if you had enough of it you could
theoretically
teleport for example the underlying data
of the entire molecular makeup of a cup
a pen
or maybe even
an entire human being
then you could use that perfect
blueprint to build an exact copy
somewhere else
far away
and that does sound at least a little
bit like
teleportation unfortunately here we hit
a snack
well about seven octillion snacks to be
precise
that's roughly how many atoms you're
made of
seven octillion it's a number so
absurdly huge it sounds like it just
made it up for effect but i didn't i
promise
to measure the quantum state and exact
position of every single atom in your
body would be akin to
precisely mapping the universe
like literally
you are made of more atoms than there
are forced to be stars in the entire 93
billion light-year observable universe
the idea we could ever simply scan
something that complicated is pushing
the boundaries of credulity
but for the sake of argument let's just
say we could
even then transferring so much data from
our scanner to some distant receiver in
order to complete a successful
sorcerer teleportation would take a very
very long time indeed exactly how long
is difficult to say with confidence but
physics students at the university of
leicester had a good go at figuring it
out and according to them to transfer
the total data required to teleport a
human being into orbit around the earth
would take somewhere in the region of 5
000 trillion years
that's quite a long time
about 350 000 times longer than the
universe has existed in case you're
wondering
assuming a fit and healthy individual
can walk about 30 miles a day
in 5 000 trillion years you could hike
well over nine million light years yeah
when your hyper futuristic teleportation
technology
is outperformed by your average unladen
human
moving at a brisk walking pace
you know you're doing something wrong
and these absurd numbers are only half
the problem anyway
let's not forget this process would only
make a copy of whatever was being
teleported
a clone
even if that clone was atom perfect to
the point it shared your thoughts
memories and feelings
it still wouldn't actually be you
if anything by teleporting in this way
all you'd really be doing is creating a
perfect doppelganger capable of sleeping
with your girlfriend without her
realizing it wasn't you
this kind of copy and paste
teleportation
seems like a non-starter
but
how about a cut and paste version
to achieve something like that we would
not only need to scan the human being
but physically
dematerialize them atom by atom
then
beam that physical matter somewhere and
re-materialize it
perfectly formed
whether or not this re-materialized
human would be any more you than the
cloned version is debatable
but that debate is probably redundant
anyway so let's not worry about it for
now
after all we have no way of taking a
human body apart piece by tiny piece
nor do we have the technology to beam
large quantities of physical matter
through other matter or even through
empty space
and even if we did i'm going to go out
on a limb here and assume that being
taken apart atom by atom
would probably make you very dead
as for all the kings horses and all the
king's men trying to put you back
together again
even with the most advanced 3d printer
imaginable
we would need to manipulate physical
matter at the atomic scale to form a
fully functioning human being based on a
blueprint that would need to be accurate
for seven octillion atoms
right down to the angstrom
that's a unit of length equal to 1 10
billionth of a meter
it's true that at the
bleeding edge of science we've been able
to 3d print internal organs including a
fully functioning human heart
but that is absolutely nothing remotely
close to the prospect of printing a
living human being
realistically any kind of teleportation
that involves scanning and transporting
a human being is pretty much a
non-starter
at least in the conceivable future but
never say never i guess many of the
technologies that seem entirely
commonplace to us today would have been
considered
impossible pipe dreams to leading
scientists just a few hundred years ago
so then that kind of sums up where we
are on the whole teleportation thing at
the moment
it requires technology so absurdly
advanced that we can't even really
imagine what they might be at the moment
as arthur c clarke once said
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and at
this point materializing a non-dead
human being out of thin air
is a technology firmly restricted to the
classrooms of hogwarts
it might not all be doom and gloom
though
if taking apart and rebuilding a human
is beyond our current abilities perhaps
we can simplify things by using a form
of teleportation that conveniently
leaves the human intact one of the most
commonly proposed ways to do this is
through handy folds in space linked by
wormholes
also known as einstein rosenbridges
now travel by wormhole isn't exactly
teleportation in the strictest sci-fi
sense
it's more like a mario kart shortcut you
don't travel any faster than you would
otherwise on the track
you just reach your destination a whole
lot sooner
unfortunately there are quite a few
problems with travel by wormhole
first and most importantly we don't
actually know for sure that wormholes
exist
we just think they probably should
according to the maths that underpins
general relativity
even if we were to find one it wouldn't
necessarily help
based on our current understanding of
what we think wormholes might be like
they should be inherently unstable
scientists have come up with some clever
ways we might be able to stabilize them
but that requires the use of so-called
exotic matter to essentially prop them
open unfortunately exotic matter matter
that is repelled rather than attracted
by gravity
like wormholes also may or may not
actually exist
so yeah this kind of teleportation
involves using a purely theoretical
substance to help us travel through
purely theoretical objects
let's just say travel by wormhole isn't
exactly a banker right now oh and i
should probably mention the small issue
that the maths we've used to predict
wormholes also seems to suggest they
would allow time travel
which plenty of scientists assume is a
big no-no in our universe for this
reason stephen hawking predicted that
travel by wormhole
may simply be impossible
basically to prevent the kind of glaring
plot holes commonly found in stories
about time travel from cropping up in
our universe
for now we simply don't know enough
about the nature of our reality to say
for sure whether or not teleportation is
a realistic possibility for our species
not just now but ever
then again it's probably a safe bet that
you won't be teleporting to work in the
coming decades
and probably not in the next few
centuries either
sorry about that but thanks for watching
do you really enjoy my content but you
literally can't be asked to use your
eyes
then you're in luck because you can now
listen to the new random interesting
facts podcast with me 42 available on
youtube spotify apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast you'll
find a link to it in the description
below check it out today and give your
eyes a break you're welcome